et bien ce dont j'ai besoin aujourd'hui
et la diva écoutez bien ce beau mais ce
qu'on est venu tout droit de la vie qui
tape tous de par sa part m ton petit que
raser bon et ton corps endroit pour lui
aucun vol au débat depuis sont dans le
doute
quand ça va faire exploser leur temps
au fond de toi
à voir
annoncé comme un souffle nouveau que ça
à
autant
ça
jours
le choc est en marche ça va faire
alors vous êtes encore ah oui j'ai pas
trouvé je vous ai dit ma gauche première
est encore à voir dsk
et puis vous tombiez la has et là bas
vous montrer la merci des salaires c'est
ici pas très bien ici dans cette danse
est devenue impossible
merci marie claude papa mais qu'est ce
que tu fais dans cette tenue
non
le blizzard
je
non
ma part je n'ai pas écouté tout le monde
tout le monde tout le monde te croyons
pas à la tradition tout le monde mais
elle se croyait à la comédie comme ça
bravo voilà
attention donnez moi ça vous touche
étoile c'est a pas eu d'explication à
donner les coordonnées vous bien que
pour bien calmement javaux exécutif
non faut pas en vouloir à marie colons
tout le monde peut pas être comme ils
font ces 11
il ya un an ici mènent des vies humaines
dont l'essentiel ce travail c'est
chimène oui tout s'est fait de tout ça
car je trouve surtout je travaille ici
on travaille la région moi tout de même
route sa robe
pourquoi pour monter des cuisines tout
ça tient là bas mais non monsieur
heureusement sa mère fait du jogging le
samedi après midi qu est qu est ce que
je vais pouvoir lui dire et vous appelez
ça du spectacle et pied comment monsieur
ici tout n'est que du spectacle de faux
cul avec tact qui te fait pour le
spectacle alors on y va les petits
canards
vivalis est assurée
tu as un talent
elle va